Well, I'm here to receive a prize for
being alive.
>> I've been living in Los Angeles for 2
years and I've never been this cold
[music] in my life.
>> Stay hungry, stay foolish.
>> These are some of the greatest speeches
of all time. People have been talking
about some of them for decades. And if
you watch them back-to-back, they look
totally different. But, they are all
doing the same exact underlying thing
because every great speech is performing
inception. Once an idea has taken
>> hold in the brain, it's almost
impossible to eradicate.
>> A great speech is built in a way that
plants an idea into the mind of the
audience. And that idea's whole purpose
is to make the audience act differently,
whether they realize it or not. So, if
you want to understand or even give one
of these incredible speeches, there is a
reliable five-step process for pulling
off inception on demand. [music] So, I'm
going to break these down using a speech
that a lot of people are calling the
best acceptance speech of the year. That
is Harrison Ford at the SAG after
lifetime achievement awards. All you
have to remember is just one word,
farts.
I know, sounds very goofy, but you will
remember it because farts is the acronym
for the five steps that you want to hit
in order. And that first letter, F,
stands for funny because 90% of the time
you want to start with humor. Ford
starts with a quip about Woody
Harrelson, which gets a chuckle from the
audience, but then he drops this.
>> I'm in a room with actors, many of whom
are here because they've been nominated
to receive a prize for their amazing
work. While I'm here to receive a prize
for being alive.
>> And his next line doubles down on the
joke.
>> That's said, it is a little weird to be
getting a lifetime achievement award
at the half point of my career.
>> Now, the reason that you want to start
with something funny is because the
first thing that you must do in any
speech is capture attention fast. And on
a per second basis, jokes are the
fastest way to do that. Now, there's two
very easy ways to be funny immediately,
even if your mind is racing. First, you
can tease the MC, and technically, that
is the first thing that Harrison does.
>> Thank you, Woody,
for that restricted introduction.
Thank you.
>> Now, this works best when it's gentle
and it's done to someone who is in a
position of status, like your boss or
the groom at his own wedding. Now, the
second way is to tease yourself, which
Ford actually does twice.
>> Well, I'm here to receive a prize for
being alive at the half point of my
career.
>> Self-deprecating humor will almost
always hit when you're in a position of
status, and giving a speech is a
position of status. So, if it's a
birthday speech, lines like, "This is
going to go horribly wrong, but thank
you all for being here." or, "Honestly,
I can't believe you all showed up." make
for very easy laughs right off the bat.
>> You serious?
>> This takes us to our second step, which
is acknowledgements, the A. Because
[music] almost every great speech will
have gratitude baked in. And whether
that's a wedding toast or a work project
wrapped or a birthday dinner, somebody
helped you. Somebody showed up, and that
means that people will feel left out if
you don't acknowledge them. But, there's
two mistakes that people make here.
First is that they skip the
acknowledgements altogether, and that
can make it seem like they think that
they did this all on their own. And
second, they will linger on
acknowledgements for too long. does his
acknowledgements in about a minute, and
there's a great line in here that you
can use whenever you're at this stage.
>> None of this happened on my own. Thank
you, George Lucas. Thank you, Steven
Spielberg.
>> None of this happened on my own. It's a
wonderful line for acknowledgements
because it's always true, and it
includes a wide variety of people. Now,
this is going to take us to the third
point, the R. This is critical. You must
relate [music] to the audience. By far,
this is the most essential part of any
speech. Because if a great speech is
Inception, R is the part where you're
bypassing people's defenses. If you do
this poorly, it will tend to go poorly.
For example, Billie Eilish got into some
internet drama when she said this at the
Grammys.
>> Don't feel like I need to say anything,
but no one is illegal on stolen land.
>> [cheering]
>> Now, at the time, the room responded
positively because they were aligned
politically, but the online backlash
that she received would have been
greatly reduced if she related more to
the general public before jumping into
her tea, which is the takeaway, but
we're going to get back to that in a
moment. So, how do you relate in a way
that opens people up to your deeper
message? Well, there are three main ways
and we tend to see them in different
contexts. [music] In political speeches,
you often see talk about shared history
or shared future vision. The speaker is
speaking for the audience. You see that
in MLK's I Have a Dream speech and JFK's
moon speech.
>> We choose to go to the moon in this
decade and do the other things, not
because they are easy, but because they
are hard.
>> In religious contexts, you'll often hear
a parable. Jesus [music] told dozens of
parables in the Gospels and you're going
to hear a list a lot in modern sermons.
What's interesting about parables is
they open people up to the lesson of the
story without activating the part of the
mind that tends to argue. But, by far
the easiest way to relate when you don't
have any parables in your back pocket or
a shared vision of the future is to do
what Ford does. And that's you just tell
a personal story. Now, a lot can be said
about great storytelling. I have a whole
section on it in Charisma University.
But, at its core, great storytelling is
sharing your specific life events with a
keen eye to the emotional relevance of
those events to the audience. This is
what bad storytellers don't get. They're
all facts and no feelings. Watch what
Ford does.
>> In my third year of college, I was a
little lost. I was failing at school. I
felt isolated, alone. And then
I found
the company of people
putting on plays. People I once thought
were
misfits and geeks turned out to be my
people. I found a calling.
>> And he repeatedly allows the
recollection of these emotions to impact
him. And you can watch how those moments
impact the audience.
>> And being able to deliver the work we
create together to an audience is
an honor. And because of that privilege,
I have come to know myself.
I'm indeed a lucky guy.
Lucky to have found my people.
Lucky to still be doing it.
>> This one-two punch of specific events
plus emotion hits because even though
the specifics of our lives are totally
different from Harrison Ford's, we share
similar emotional experiences. So, when
you tell a story that is about you, but
you make the emotional journey the
focus, the audience will instinctively
feel, "Oh, I'm like him." And this sets
you up for the next part of relating,
which is the part where you shift from
saying "I" in your personal story to
"we" in the collective story. And Ford
nails this.
>> As actors, we get to live many lives. We
get to explore ideas. The stories we
tell have a unique capacity to create
moments of emotional connection.
>> So, once they feel like you are like
them, they're way more open to accepting
the move from this "I" [music] to "we."
And it means that they're going to be
open to following you to the next step,
which is the T in F.A.R.T.S., which is
the whole point of the great speech.
This is the takeaway. And the takeaway
answers just one question: How does the
audience walk away changed? Now, unless
you are an incredibly skilled public
speaker, this is something that you need
to consider before you give your speech.
It's the one thing you need to know in
advance because you're building
everything around it. Ford wants the
audience, who are all successful actors,
to reconsider how they treat the
younger, less experienced people on
their sets. That's exactly why he told
that lost college kid story. So, when he
moves on to tell them about the
responsibility to pay it forward, that's
going to land because they just spent
the last few moments empathizing with
the kid that they're thinking about.
>> Success in this business brings a
certain freedom. It comes with
responsibility to support each other, to
keep the door open for the next kid, the
next lost boy who's looking for a place
to belong.
>> And you notice here, he uses the same
exact phrase, lost boy, to describe
himself at 20 as he does to describe the
people that he wants the audience to
care for. So, generally speaking, it's
very good practice to have a handful of
really good stories in your back pocket.
You want these with widely applicable
takeaways. Especially important, this is
going to come in handy for interviews
where the classic question is, "Tell me
about a time you succeeded in a
difficult situation or a challenge you
overcame." And most people freeze here
because they don't have these stories
pre-built. Knowing a handful of key
stories where the takeaway is, "I can
work through challenging things." will
come in super clutch in these
situations. Now, there are actually two
kinds of takeaways and it is worth
knowing the difference. You've got your
soft close. That's where you're asking
the audience just to see something
differently. Ford's "Keep the door
open." is a soft close. It's a belief
shift. It's not a concrete action. And
then, there are the hard closes. That's
where you're asking the audience to do
something specific. Donate to charity.
Call your mother today. Buy Charisma
University. These are hard closes and
hard closes involve immediate action,
which makes them more powerful, but also
much more challenging to earn. You need
to really nail this relating part, the
art, to justify that hard close
takeaway. Now, this takes us to the last
letter, the S, the sign-off. By this
point, you have done what you need to
do. You open the audience up with humor,
gratitude, emotional connection. You've
planted your takeaway. This is now just
about letting people know, "Hey, we're
[music] done." The big mistake that
people make here is they linger. They're
not sure how to end, so they drag things
out and they ramble for 5 minutes and
then they just kind of peter out and the
audience thinks, "It's okay, it's time
for applause." The way you want to avoid
this is to pre-plan one sentence that
signals your out. I always know if I get
lost in a script, I can just say,
"Either way, hope you've enjoyed this
video and I look forward to seeing you
in the next [music] one." So, what you
want to do is just plan one line that
can be your exit. Four tends to land on
a light joke and that's a great idea.
>> And thank you, Sacha Baron Cohen,
for honoring me with this prize. This is
very encouraging.
>> So, now you've got these basics of
building an amazing speech even on the
fly. And if you want to go deeper into
the storytelling aspect that I mentioned
so you can whip these killer stories out
at a cocktail party or an interview or
you're just interested in raising your
confidence across the board in any
social setting, you may be interested in
joining Charisma University. [music]
It's a step-by-step 30-day program that
tells you exactly what to do every day
so that by the end of it, you are
radiating confidence and charisma
without even thinking about it. Here's
just a few things that our past members
have said. "I had confidence in some
areas but not [music] in others. Then
Charisma University changed that for me.
Since beginning the program, I have seen
noticeable changes in my life. It has
helped me unlock the confidence that
comes with knowing that I can go into
any social situation and crush it."
Another member wrote, "I've always been
bad at expressing myself in situations
that weren't one-on-one in
conversations. I'd find myself hesitant
to speak or I'd get caught in my own
head overthinking things. After CU, I am
now way more confident in saying what I
think. I feel much happier all the time.
I was even able to talk the woman I've
had a crush on for about a year and made
a great first impression. Overall, I
love this course and I keep going back
to it when I need a refresher on the
daily action modules. This program is
literally guaranteed to change your
life, which means that you can take the
entire course and if you don't think
it's worth every penny, you can give
yourself a full refund right from inside
the program. So, if you want to see if
this course is right for you, click the
link on the screen now or in the
description below. Either way, I hope
that you've enjoyed today's video and I
hope to see you in the next one."